swiss voters have outlawed covering your
face in public
finally no more fanatics covering their
face with bees
what's wrong with you people but another
group upset with the outcome of this
vote is switzerland's
muslim community
[Music]
mostly muslim women to be precise
because this law will ban them from
wearing burqas and kneecaps but
considering that according to research
by the university of lucerne
almost nobody in switzerland wears a
burqa and only around 30 women wear the
nikab
what's the point of this law
the face covering ban was proposed by
the right-wing swiss people's party or
svp
the same group that put forward the
proposal for banning the building of
minarets that passed in a 2009
referendum
the organizers of the referendum to ban
minarets want to make sure no
more are built they regard minarets as a
symbol of political and religious claims
to power
not a religious sign switzerland has
that direct democracy perk where they
can hold referendums on
almost anything so that citizens can
decide on laws that govern them
i love them i get the argument that if
you live here
you should adjust to our way of life i
get that and it does hold merit but the
west has been projecting to the rest of
the world for decades that they welcome
diversity we're all big gay friends here
would you like to live with us unlike
some countries from which many
immigrants fled
the burka ban campaign was pretty much a
fear campaign
oh oh you've got it all wrong my little
friend
with posters showing a woman in a black
knick up with captions such as
stop extremism first of all political
violence throughout history
isn't linked to the clothing that women
wear otherwise lady gaga's cleaning
starter pack dress would have sparked
global unrest
second i thought that the western way of
life was about letting people make their
own choices
don't be gay spark feminists in
switzerland were torn on the issue
because many of you the burka and nikab
as oppressive to women but they also
oppose laws telling women what they can
and cannot wear
which led to many women answering
opinion polls with yang
a cross between yah and nine because yes
it's tricky so let me frame it like this
for women
it makes no difference whether the dress
code is set by their religion or the
state
hey starch you do not disrespect strong
woman by talking when she's talking
you really think i couldn't have handled
that myself the woman should be the one
who decides
on the dress code enough of this
blasphemy life in a majority muslim
country or majority christian country
so long as there is a dress code set by
the government it's all the same to
women
and considering that almost nobody in
switzerland wears burqas and nicobs at
the moment
this preemptive measure might have the
opposite effect because the best way to
radicalize
any group of people is to ban them from
making their own
choices we can't let this happen it'll
be the end of imagination land
but the svp's aim was to stop radical
[Music]
islam
you